they're an inventive design duo that
finds ingenious uses for waist kind of
we don't want to make purely decorative
objects they have to have a function and
most of all they have to be well-made
beautiful products
you only notice the recycling or
upcycling when you take a second look
product designers cost until and Dennis
Snelling founded the lock and alert
factory in 2004 they sell their
one-of-a-kind objects online or out of a
store in downtown Hamburg everything
used to be under one roof the workshop
was down in the cellar the shop was over
there and the office was over here over
the years we got bigger and we just
couldn't manage some aspects of
production anymore now they have a
good-sized workshop outside Hamburg
where they and their employees
manufacture their designs they also have
room to store their materials here like
surplus oil barrels and broken
skateboards for anyone else it may look
like trash but for the people here it's
a resource it all started quite
pragmatically nuts cups of tea at the
time we had no clue about upcycling per
say it was more about finding materials
that we didn't have to pay for to
repurpose the old records trained
industrial electrician Dennis developed
a special machine to remould the vinyl
discs into balls he's continuously
optimized the production process at
first each piece was one-of-a-kind then
we realized that if a shop were to buy
our stock it would have to be at half
price so they could make a profit and so
we started mass-producing the aliens who
would have seen
[Music]
Denis spends most of his time in the
workshop while Carsten generally looks
after the store the online shop and
acquiring materials they collect used
skateboards from skater shops all over
Germany we'll ask a skateboard shop if
they'll put out our box their advantage
is that they can offer to recycle their
customers boards and we'll pick them up
our advantage
is that we use the boards as raw
materials the designers plan to tree for
every fifth skateboard they get in the
past two years they've up cycled three
hundred and seventy-five skateboards
translating into 75 planted trees Locke
and Gillett has already won several
prizes including the green product award
in 2015 for their best selling key
novels they make over old books as key
or coat racks the idea for the key hook
novels is such a simple one but it
yields such an incredible variety of
nice things actually that's always the
best part of discovering a new idea you
can vary it to come up with the wildest
objects now Karsten twill and Dennis
melting art work developing their first
jewelry line but whether it's books
skateboards or records the two designers
from Hamburg never run out of ideas
[Music]
you
[Music]